today the yankees the orioles
and all of major league baseball join as
one
to remember those that lost their lives
on september 11
2001. we pay tribute to them
and to the men and women who serve our
country
as we honor the pledge made 19 years ago
today
we shall not forget
settling for two everybody a couple of
seven inning games
and the two two lined in the center
field gardner is there to make the play
one away see the yankees wearing the
nypd hat
to honor the first responders
that one is looped to second base wade
is there two away
see if he's got that put away pitch
today he put him away
he had it right there stewart swings and
misses right-hander alex cobb
he returns from the injured list he has
been sidelined
since september the fourth to the ninth
big league season
now here's dj to lead it off
driven to left field and deep going back
is mount castle on the track at the wall
see ya a lead off home run for dj lemayo
yankees on the board they're up one
nothing
after cop jumps ahead 0-2 with a couple
sinkers away right
on the outside corn it gets one out over
the plate and dj lemay you
know what it is about his first at bat
but he likes to go deep
got the yankees on the board with hits
against alex
cobb and brett gardner makes his way to
the plains
that one's driven deep to right field
steward back turning looking sia
a two-run home run for gardner and the
yankees jump out to a three-nothing lead
coney you stated you couldn't ask for a
better start score some runs early and
then
give the ball to garrett cole he'd been
much better at limiting home runs this
season
as torres fisks one into center and
mullins is there out number two
this ballpark ball can really get out of
here
kerry sanchez with a line drive the
other way but valencia is there
strike three severino down looking and
he knew it
you see different yankees are either
wearing an nypd cap
and others are wearing an fdny cap
again on the 19th anniversary of the
attacks of
9 11 in 2001 and the first responders
that
acted with unbelievable bravery
swinging a miss as nunes down on strikes
he leads off with a single
that'll bring up higashiyoka
that one is driven to left field and
deep mount castle back he's on the track
he's at the wall
sia a two-run home run for higashiyoka
and the bronx bombers are out this
afternoon
it's five nothing yankees
the 3-2 swinging at a miss
blake it down on strikes
line to right field on the run frazier
and he makes the play for the first out
2-2 struck him out swinging
breaking ball down and in and they're a
two-way strikeout number five
i'll tell you what you're a cold today
coney has really used that breaking ball
and the slider just as an out pitch
check swing higashiyoka did go according
to adam back at first
oh really good pitch beautiful paint job
there
from cobb
lemay hue chases a breaking ball and
cobb strikes out the last three of the
inning
and you have to give credit to major
league baseball
swing and a miss in the dirt
put out 2-3 eric cole off for sixth
inning of work he's allowed
just one hit throw correctly at that
loss
and then he goes with the slider and
gets iglesias for the second out
swing and a miss strikeout number eight
eight strikeouts one walk one hit what a
game he spits some
orioles bring the infield in halfway at
second and short with torres on third
and sanchez at second that one is looped
into center field that's going to dunk
in for a base hit
torres scores easily sanchez moves to
third and talkman has his third hit the
yankees have a six nothing lead
so derek cole will try to finish this
out
swing and a miss strikeout number nine
for coal
and the oreos are down to their final
out and the pitch
chopped right back to coal he fields
fires and a beauty
a two-hit shutout for garrett cole as
the yankees win this one
6-0